should have been a trip to carali he even
looked around at the officials I think the
fans got it right the officials miss that one
Milano cruising in Sunny Deep slot pass bang
bang and Mer lein made a good stop there Milano
skitters away from the pressure of Prov off the
former flyer mantha deals to sandine those two
isolating around carali mantha closes fires
stopped by m leens and there's no rebound had
it deflected Away by sson and the Blue Jackets
Roar ahead carali with a step on the defender
backand stopped by lingren and he'll cover and
this is a guy that really burns up the ice talk
about their for Johnny gdo through Center gdow
double team looks across ice cing drag give and
go that's pretty lining from between his skats
denied there by lingren at the doorstep for play
back for the conclusion of this opening period
in Capital One as the blue Jack it's off the
give and [Music] go he'll be a an able-bodied
penalty killer too now joining Washington's ranks
and that group's been pretty incredible the last
two weeks oetkin fires off the inside of the
post passing rer here he gets it good little
play give and go and Watcher gets fir it and
he had The goenda Far Side blocker look at his
speed nice touch pass by villinger angles in and
fires he missed the target delayed penalty call
coming up against the Caps m leens to the bench
for the extra attacker six on five gdo walks in
and fires he scores Johnny gdo and stick Taps on
the Columbus Blue jacket's bench it's been a long
time you know he's a guy that always scores he
only has one goal on the season with the goalie
pulled on the delayed penalty here's the rotation
there's one pass boom Jenner lays it out to him
and and that is a rocket ship launched by Johnny
hockey right over the catching Miss of lingren and
Columbus on the board first here in Washington
caps workor the cycle all that's diffused by
the defense of the Blue Jackets B re D sent it far
corner there's Ganson round and round with Milano
another chance to the goal mouth angled Away
by mer leol followup score Sunny Milano ties it
tonight he scores on Ms leans on his first
shot nice little rotation and notice a perfect
triangle down there hunting down pucks well done
protus and he fires it across look at protus out
muscle where ransy through bran entire six weeks
that goal came out Ottawa L fires good glove save
there lingren showing off the reflexes they both
can shoot a ton watch them collect get it in the
Wheelhouse and fire it two came very easy the
third one kept me awake at night protus on the
go fires off the crossbar and down the red light
is on protus celebrates the Caps have the lead I
was just praising Alexi protus and The Twig
had a lot of torque through stick he broke
his one stick went to the bench got a new one
and just looked at the flex and the torque of
that shot right under the bar beautiful passing
play look at everybody join the rush short Side
High hit the middle bar and out in a hurry
there it is you can see the neet Bulge all
the buddy on the ice knew that short usually
when Locker asks about 40 of them show up on
his door they're delivered yes mantha behind
the D mantha right on in to his backand stopped
by m leakin a clutch thing save there that's
ambitious and langway started at like 15 right
decided to play Big stop there Le huge Anthony
Mana using his reach to try to get it around
that left leg and I think we'll be having four
on four here carali and TJ Oshi all tangled up
at the end of this play there's the tackle
at the end I think both of them would going
off for two minutes there's that backhand shot
trying to go between the arm and the pad just
didn't get it through minutes each for ruing
matching miners for ruffing Locker back to
the mantha shot why is it so difficult Edmonson
through Center soaring into the zone and sending
it hard around shade more than four minutes with
which to work in the second Str great pass oetkin
score three unanswered for the
cats first trip someone the puck look at they
have three guys down there missplay by ransy
trying to go up the wall Four Guys caught three
behind the goal line it's four on four you got
to have man on man you have to have someone in
front they don't have anybody and the Rolling
Puck OB be the best at shooting anything that no
score after one Johnny gdo gave the Blue Jackets
a one- nothing lead in the second now the Caps
have a two-on-one developing Valenstein denied
there by m leans spun in by marenstein ER is
there he'll turn 20 next week with 55 in the
white Carlson on the reverse uh-oh backhand
chance lingren the save another pad stop on
singer the scramble they score proov dumps it
in it's 3-2 they just seem to hang around game
in game out control the third one by Provo there's
the reverse that doesn't work out the shot doesn't
get through and watch in front of the net the
Mad scramble in the final poke by proov who
came all the way in a good job by cylinder taking
it to the net hard it's kicked back Washington is
challenging the previous play to determine if
there was go tender interference prior to the
goal and I believe it is by the rule of the law
the ones that we've seen this year go against
carbur upon video review the play on
the ises of good goal lost it there
to l l on the tow drag move his pass
was intended for singer Milano sends
in leier Hendrick leier backand he scores
a three point performance for [Applause]
LEF watch this play by Sunny Milano working along
the bar imediate up and what about a backand top
Corner shot it looked like it went a little
bit over the blocker maybe through the body
right there and squirts through excellent shot
and a beautiful Play All Around starting with
the breakup Milano laier that drift away that
gave him enough room to let that shot go the
defender was right on his heels and he drifted
away number one and that also moved the goalie
by the way and that's why there was room seven
hole because he shifted his upper body and that
allowed that puck obviously I exagger at by saying
Boston would stink but there were people who are
worried with them losing the likes of berson
and C from the center spot quick passing score
Dan for doorstep it's a one-goal game yep that's
at fourth line doing it for Columbus a beautiful
pass by carali by the way foiled everybody
in front forth and he makes no mistake here
it is where ransky Chip Shot there's the pass by
caral and Danforth on the Finish but it all starts
rinsky off the back wall beautiful little de pass
there by the way by corali getting it through and
there's a little backhander and there's a top
Corner snipe by Dan for lensky staves him off
finds fan Tilly it's four on three at this end
good drow on the delay McNugget minut into the
third deflection lingren Great Stop on Jenner
who slams The Glass in disgust that was all
Johnny hockey on the transition Boon Jenner the
captain look at that little lane and he found him
perfectly at the end of the line and Lindgren
saw it coming read it and tracked it perfectly
real nice stop there at the end of this third
period remember as you see the reaction from
Jenner the Caps don't have a timeout Columbus is
just taken to the corner Jenner from his knees to
Severson 3 seconds left gadell fires blocked there
melen Stein seals the deal Washington holds a 43
win